il est arrivé sur une barge le premier
tronçon de la grande passerelle a pris
place l'un des 19 novembre sur le pont
reliant la place de l'étape à
mantes-la-jolie au théâtre de verdure de
l'île aux dames c'est une une opération
extrêmement délicate qui prend 48 heures
pendant 48 euros qu'une péniche ne
passera sur ce bras de seine pour
pouvoir faciliter cette installation 105
mètres de long et 7 m de large pour une
passerelle total de 201 m réservé aux
piétons et aux cyclistes
elle entre dans un projet global en
faveur de la mobilité douce de 9,6
millions d'euros financé en majorité par
la région ile de france le département
des yvelines a contribué à 11%
la mise en route de cette passerelle
correspond à cette volonté de faire que
ce lieu traditionnel de passage d'une
rive à l'autre remplisse toutes les
fonctions qui sont les siennes dans la
société d'aujourd'hui
la structure est en acier et elle est
revêtue de bois l'architecte l'a imaginé
comme une terrasse reliant les
centre-ville de mantes-la-jolie et de
l'hymne est clos
les décès mais on repart avec le point
existants qui impose routier qui est un
pont droit en fait c'est assez lourd
assez présente dans le site nous c'est
le léger se veut sauver d'où se veut un
peu justement ambulante pour être en
harmonie avec le fleuve avec le paysage
le chantier devrait prendre fin à l'est
vers 2019
cette passerelle correspond à la
première étape du nouveau franchissement
entre les deux villes le vieux pont
situé de l'autre côté sera rénové et
agrémenté lui aussi d'une passerelle
les deux ouvrages seront ensuite relié
par un cheminement piéton et cyclable
sur l'île aux dames